[Music]
III is fast approaching and will soon
learn about all the hot new games we get
to play over the next year or so but if
you're a PlayStation Plus subscriber and
want to know what you can play in June
for free I've got you covered and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
be the first to know about the PS Plus
lineup every month kicking things off on
ps4 is life is strange
this time-traveling highschool adventure
game is all about the choices you make
strange things are happening in the town
of Arcadia Bay and it's up to heroine
max Caulfield to save the town and her
closest friends on the other side of the
spectrum is monster shooter Killing
Floor 2 up to six players can band
together to battle waves of walking bio
monsters called Zed's whether you're a
medic or commando you'll have to play
your part to help your squad survive ps3
players can jump into abyss Odyssey
where a team of heroes has to fight and
platform their way to an evil warlock
the procedurally generated levels are a
mix of platforming and combat and the
rat art style ain't too shabby either if
you're more into racing than adventuring
WRC 5 has you covered the World Rally
Championship game contains tons of cars
from the racing leagues 2015 season plus
hundreds of miles of tracks to race
across better start revving those
engines PS Vita owners can chew things
up in neon chrome which is part top-down
shooter part roguelike you can choose
between different classes and level up
your character until you're fully
equipped to take on the overseer insert
fallout joke here and finally the Vita
is also getting spy chameleon as the
name implies you take on the role of the
color-changing reptile your mission
sneak around and avoid being caught by
blending in makes sense and don't forget
you can play both of these Vita games on
ps4 as well thanks to cross by all of
these games will be available Tuesday
June 6th when the PSN store refreshes
you can always check out gameplay clips
and reviews for these titles over at
GameSpot too and if you want to keep up
to date with all the most popular
stories grab the official game spot now
app on
iOS and Android
you